So yesterday, I interviewed Ben Dixon, host of
the Benjamin Dixon Show, and we talked about
what could Joe Biden focus on next early last
week? The rumor was the report was that tax
reform would be next after covid relief now being
done. Earlier this week, we heard it's going to be
a three trillion dollar infrastructure, schools
and families package, which will be next. But in
the back of all of this is the push to expand
voting rights. And there's a, I would argue,
a very strong case to be made that the advantage
of going next to voting rights is twofold. Number
one, it's of paramount importance to win elections
that as many people be able to vote as possible
and that Republicans not be allowed
to succeed with what they are doing.
Remember that Republicans, in the aftermath of the
2020 election launched proposed roads are starting
to work on more than two hundred and fifty
different voter suppression bills across more than
40 states. So not only is the issue of expanding
voting rights relevant for winning elections,
it's a particularly timely importance because
Republicans are trying to do the exact opposite.
In addition to this, there's the context of the
filibuster. Now, we'll get in a moment to what is
in the voting rights bill that the House passed.
But if you were thinking, as Democrats are,
we may need to do something with the filibuster
to get things done in the next two years
with Democrats having the White House, House
and Senate. And it's the filibuster being
there that may prevent us from doing that.
Is there any better issue over which we could
justify doing? Again, it's a modification of
the filibuster elimination. We don't know.
But what would be a better case to make than
this is about voting? Republicans are blocking
voting rights. We must do something with
the filibuster. So that's the if you want
to make a case for why it should indeed be voting
rights expansion that should be focused on first,
you could make the case that it's because
Republicans are actively doing the opposite.
So Democrats must push back against those two
hundred and fifty bills, because if you believe
you'll need filibuster changes to get other things
done, it's probably politically more viable.
To justify changing the filibuster over something
as important as like, listen, you know, with guns,
I think it would be justified in theory to
modify the filibuster, to try to get things done.
But I think from a public relations standpoint,
it would be more difficult with something like
this is voting rights. You arguably have the
most justifiable reason to do it. Now, would
there be any Republican support for this voting
rights bill in the Senate? My understanding is
and again, this is a topic that often there's
disagreement about. I don't believe that
there's a budget reconciliation argument to
be made for voting rights because it's not
it's not a budget issue. It's not a spending
issue, although certainly some of the initiatives
cost money. Maybe I'm wrong and you could do
voting rights via budget reconciliation. I've
not read anything so far that says you could. And
in the House, the 800 page bill passed basically
along party lines. And it does a ton of stuff, not
all of which Republicans want, much of which some
Republicans want. None of this bill would create
minimum standards for states in terms of how they
must run elections, federal standards that states
must abide by. It would basically destroy a lot of
the voter ID proposals and laws in a variety
of different states. It would restore voting
rights to former felons, period, not states will
vote as as a referendum. No, it just it restores
voting rights to former felons. It puts in place
requirements like automatic voter registration,
no excuse mail in balloting, which means
you don't need a qualifying reason to
explain why you want to vote by mail. You can just
say, I want to vote by mail and that's it. And a
lot of these provisions are the exact opposite of
what Republicans at the state level are doing now.
It's important to remember many of the Republicans
in the Senate who would be voting on this bill
don't necessarily have the same
perspective or opinion on these issues
as the state level Republican legislators that are
working on the and on the voter suppression bills.
But still, I don't know that you get any
Republican support for this. The other thing
is on gerrymandering and gerrymandering, we've
talked about many times over the years this bill
that has passed the House and we'll see what
happens in the Senate would require states
to use independent commissions to draw
congressional districts. And right now,
this would significantly hurt Republicans.
You could imagine a situation in the future
where it's Democrats who have gotten
to draw the majority of the districts
and such a provision could hurt Democrats. But
remember that even who gets to draw the districts
aside because of the urban rural divide, it
favors Republicans in in terms of districts
drawing at at a sort of core level. So that's
a huge deal. Republicans know that part of the
reason they win some districts in purple states,
even in red states, is by drawing them in very
particular ways if we've exposed before. So this
is a this is a major deal if it could be done.
And what needs to be balanced by Joe Biden and
by Democrats here in terms of determining whether
this is the next thing that they want to deal
with is, number one, the importance and the
urgency given that there's an election now in,
what, two, five minus 19 months were 19 months
from the midterms. And if Republicans just do what
they're doing in all of these different states,
it will hurt the left in twenty twenty two,
there's no doubt. So there's that urgency. There's
the justification for using enfranchisement as a
valid reason to do something with the filibuster,
maybe do away with maybe just reform and mandate
attacking a mandate, a talking filibuster,
maybe make some other changes. And because it
could set up the possibility of the infrastructure
plan and of other things in the remainder of
these first two years of Joe Biden's term. So
that's the gist of it. I'm curious to hear from
you. What do you want Joe Biden and Democrats
focusing on next? Should it be the tax reform
plan, which I think politically is the most
difficult at this point in time, given the
circumstances with the pandemic and economy,
which we'll talk about in a moment? Should it
be the infrastructure spending plan where there
is maybe some more Republican support, but they
will be opposed to much of it? Or is it the voting
rights expansion? Let me know what you would
like to see Joe Biden and Democrats tackle next.